boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation i'm your host alan sakhyan
very excited to be on site still in
boston massachusetts we are now going to
be talking about what it's like to go
through a process of getting into ivy
league schools we're going to be talking
about a lot of high level conversation
around finding meaning in life i'm
really excited to be sitting down with
whitney nimitz batana hello hi everyone
thanks for coming out to the show thanks
for inviting me greatly appreciate i'm
really excited to talk to you we have a
lot to talk about i'm really happy that
alex chen introduced us yeah alex alex
is the best i'm really glad i got the
opportunity to meet you i feel really
honored because um i think if he thinks
that i'm interesting enough to be
interviewed well so be it we had a lot
of good conversation last night i did
yeah yeah i'm super pumped for this
there's a lot of good stuff to unpack
about your life and about um where we're
gonna go with this convo excited um okay
let's talk about this because this i
don't think many people even realize
what goes into the process of like
working someone's ass off until they're
like 17 18 and then going and getting
into a bunch of different ivy league
colleges this is hard
hard work um okay so you were born in
brooklyn right no so actually i guess so
um
i guess just how do where do i start the
story um so i guess um so i'm both my
parents are ethnically chinese but my
mom is from burma which is also known as
myanmar and she grew up around the
capital whereas my dad is from thailand
and he also grew up around the capitol
there um both of them immigrated to the
u.s around the time they were teenagers
or their early 30s i mean tony's i
believe
and then in new york yep directly in new
york city and that's where they met too
okay and then um so when i was um so
when my mom was um gave birth to me um
we were living in manhattan in that time
around the chinatown area okay and then
when i was very young around four year
old four years old that's when we moved
to brooklyn okay
and then okay so this is already
interesting because we a lot of us have
had these sort of parents that have come
from other places and immigrated to the
united states and and were raised
children in the united states with a
kind of like a cultural lineage from a
different part of the world
okay so when you're you ended up now at
four years old in brooklyn and you did
you grew up with brothers and sisters
too yep i have one older sister an older
sister okay and how many years older is
she two years old if susie if you're
watching this hi shout out to susie
shout out susie um okay so then you're
growing up with her you're four she's
six
and what is that like with your parents
with you figuring out who you are in the
world tell us about that
i think that at that age um you don't i
think you don't really know enough about
the world or at least like um most
people don't know about the world enough
about the world in order to in order to
um
i think to really fathom like the sort
of um i think because especially given
that now are very it's very tumultuous
and also some very anxious times i don't
think we know we knew about all of that
growing up um i think i'm also i'm very
lucky to have lived in a very diverse
ethnically socio-economically um in
terms of like religious background
neighborhood and that also that also
affected me based on where i went to
elementary school in middle school and
high school
okay so it was
socioeconomically religiously culturally
diverse yes yeah in brooklyn growing up
yep
it's very interesting because i'm
growing up i think that's something i
took for granted when i was younger
because i think a lot of people
especially when you live in more
racially homogenous areas you don't
really i think the one thing the thing
about new york city is that you
literally have people from every single
ethnic category in like perhaps in the
same like square mile
and so you grow up so i like i grew up
eating it um you know um like chinese
food turkish food russian food jewish
food i mean like you know like kosher
food all like all that good stuff
and then i think it's just that um you
you grew up you grew up like in this
very it seems like the world is very
tolerant like there's a it's such a
mixing pot and then you go to other
places and then you realize that oh the
world is actually more homogenous in
certain places and so in a certain place
it's not actually so um i guess like you
don't actually have like people who come
with like lots of different certain like
viewpoints in those places
yeah but okay so that right there is a
huge point that you just brought up
because i
grew up in a vastly white uh area of
south dakota and when you grow up there
it's it's odd when you see people that
look different than a white person yeah
exactly that is weird because when you
grow up in brooklyn you get to see all
of the different cultures you get
they're afraid you're they're they're
not different they're human yes exactly
yes i mean and then also i think the
thing is even if like people are like
like so hollywood has a long way to go
in terms of representation
of minority people i think the thing is
that you also grew up will grow up with
all these divers knowing all people of
all different races and ethnicities and
exactly like you said exactly that um
makes them very human um so you i think
it's like
i mean well i guess like you could say
that rachel like vice racial prejudices
still exist between like um like
cultures i think at the same time i feel
like it's um yeah it's a very humbling
experience um and i feel like um
it's i guess like real is the word that
i would use to describe it yeah i'm glad
that we made sure to touch on the
humanization side of things as we
melting pot our cultures together it
becomes a whole a planet full of humans
and that's um moving forward how we can
prosper most effectively is when we
treat each other that way
okay so growing up in the melting pot
and then slowly but surely figuring out
what you wanted to do a little bit in
your high school so tell us about this
sure um i think i didn't like so i think
everyone's very familiar with um the
tiger parent archetype but i think it
would i mean like actually kind of um
unique in the sense that my parents like
we i never i was never really pushed to
become like oh you have to become an
engineer or a doctor well of course
there's um i was always taught that okay
to have ambitions and to want to achieve
more but at the same time i think they
were also chill in certain aspects as
long as i got good grades and i got into
a good school then that's all and then i
got i you know i chose a lucrative
career path and that's all that mattered
yeah this
even
even that sort of parenting of
like you know we worked so hard to
to bring you into the world and make
sure you do something that's lucrative
and
there's there's a sort of a
the it's important the most important
thing is for that the child just has
their fullest potential brought into the
world exactly yeah
it's funny because i think um so there's
this facebook group called subtle asian
memes that's exploded in popularity in
the past month
and i think there's one meme that really
stands out to me because um a lot of um
like especially um first like first
generation asian parents they come here
they teach their children they enroll
their children in music lessons for the
piano and violin and usually only those
two instruments because there's some
sort of um i think clout with those
instruments with those specific
instruments so no like guitar or
anything wacky
and then and then so and then you and
they like they um they encourage their
children to continue with music lessons
and to achieve um and to continue
playing those instruments but then when
let's say if like you're if but then
when they're children like they let's
say like um you would you would think
that the
logical path is to become um like to
pursue a career in music after all that
musical training but that's obviously um
forbidden that's like sort of forbidden
because of that because it's a creative
um career
so i think it's just like that sort of
that like dichotomy is like something
that i just like said that yeah it's
something that's very ironic
and i want because i think i feel like
down the line we're gonna end up
figuring out a more effective way to
uh open up
uh both an equality of opportunity for
young kids to figure out what they're
passionate about and do it and also for
parents to
figure out
you know motivate the kids but also
give them you know congratulate them
when they do well along the way and
don't maybe
sward off some sort of part of their
creativity because it may not be
lucrative
because we're going to potentially start
the market's potentially going to start
correcting and going towards creativity
a little bit more it already is
in some regards i i think that's
accurate to say um for one thing i'm i
strongly believe that um change begins
um on at the generational level so um us
some like one like you know first and
second generation kids who were brought
up in the u.s and other countries
as part of this some asian diaspora i
think um we recognize that
our parents did the best they could like
when they were raising us and while
their methods may not have been the best
um i think it's on us to to make sure
that um our offspring um that we like
that we push them in the right
directions so that they can achieve
their full potential regardless we don't
have to focus on just stem or careers
that we consider lucrative or
prestigious
we want them to achieve like to the best
of their ability and i and to your point
i think in terms of rewarding creativity
i think especially i think
i think this just popped in my head but
i think um especially as jobs get more
more and more jobs get automated
just some building creativity and other
soft skills especially just some you
know being able i think those will
become more and more important as we as
like um a lot of our of the current jobs
get automated but the new jobs will i
think new jobs will arise based on that
um you know
based on how society is changing
yeah i'm glad that you're
really honing in on
creativity and social emotional skills
being
super important as automation arises
they're gonna it's a it's gonna be a
very interesting transition that occurs
in the next couple of decades and for us
we are
around 25-ish versus for kids that are
born today when in 2045 things are going
to be
incredibly
challengingly uh different to what is it
going to be like to be creative in 25
years and what is going to be like to go
through the high school process so
as as as okay so as
i know we can go off so many ways wendy
and i can talk about a bunch of
different things together um
and let's let's come let's come to this
because you you know you mentioned this
already once and i want to see if we can
maybe even identify some of the uh the
culture the cultural transgenerational
sort of
pr the
pressures that occur that kind of
that make it so that parents act in a
certain way with their kids that
potentially maybe
drives them in a certain direction
rather than uh enables them to freely
explore and figure out who they are
sure
um i guess like where should we start
then
okay well you brought up well you
brought up tiger parenting and you kind
of gave that you gave you gave it a good
example um
because okay let's start let's start
maybe with this um we've seen time and
time again more and more data showing
that the more that
you are born into low ses the different
your life outcome is from someone that's
born into a high socioeconomic status
that similar sort of concept can be
applied to your parent your parenting if
the parenting skills are high openness
high explorativity versus if it's a nope
you've got to follow this path and this
is what only things that we're giving
you
something like that yeah i can imagine
that being the case because parents who
are higher openness and more open to
other methods i think um they're more
able to adapt their um
their parenting to different sort of
sorts of personalities and just provide
a fostering environment for their
children and of course um i think like
yeah having of course having more means
too also means that you can um prepare
your child for this rat race um
sooner
it's like
it's very interesting because i read an
article recently on buzzfeed um they
have pretty good long-form pieces
besides just besides their listicles
about millennials being the burnout
generation i think and one of the tenets
of that piece was that um
we were everyone is so at least people
our age are so so burnt out all the time
is because um
we were raised to optimize all aspects
of our life from not and not just our
like our career and academics but even
our leisure so it's like oh um things
that were that we would do in our off
time like exercise or eating or even
cleaning are things that have to be um
optimized as well
give me a little more on the
optimization of what what is that like
tell me about that
i guess maybe one example is that like
um i feel like nowadays especially like
um with the um proliferation of the of
social media and how that gives you like
sort of like a panopticon into what
everyone is doing
um i think you're like there's a lot of
more more like uh moralism regarding um
how people eat so for example like the
shift towards some organic and vegan
foods i think i i can't help but notice
that there's also some a little a change
of um like moralism there and which
which sort of says like oh the
quote-unquote cleaner you eat the better
of a person you are i mean at the end of
the day it's like you know eating is
just eating it's like for fun and i
think and especially for people who grew
up in imminent immigrant families um
it's also part of your culture and your
childhood as well
and who is to determine what clean is or
what good is
well okay sure clean energy okay we can
probably determine that solar wind yeah
exactly
things that don't um
that things that don't contribute to
environmental pollutants but with
regards to quote-unquote clean eating
who gets to decide
it's like trying to decide who gets to
decide what hate speech is and that's
been a pressing issue that um is
permeating through culture right now is
people throttling uh of the pay of
artists and comedians and other
performers because they're deciding on
whether or not that performer is using
hate speech or not who gets to decide
how does civilization figure out what of
course there's a big difference between
things like the kkk between someone
that's trying to make a a statement
about about potentially race or gender
or um obesity or whatever it may be
and now all of a sudden they can't
potentially do that what's up with the
clean food too you can't you tout around
a veganism attitude or a carnivorism
attitude and you may potentially
be stuck in a single mode of thought
that's not open to again experience
looping back to what we're talking about
with
parents as well hmm
now do you make a you make a very
interesting connection there
in terms of freedom of speech i think um
i think it's a very especially like
where we live in an age where we're
saturated with information and we have
unprecedented access to information
through our facebook news feed do our
twitter feeds do everything um so not
only do we get the nitty-gritty details
on what people are or or you know our
social circles are doing or rather what
they want us to see that they're doing
um i think we'll probably like touch on
this topic later yeah um
but we i think like so once some someone
released so let's say an artist releases
a song then that and that i think like
people because of how ubiquitous um
social media is people um
are free and especially since you have
the freedom to you technically have the
freedom to say anything you want on the
internet so people feel like
people are going to say what they want
to say and then i think it's just that
before like perhaps like in a different
age we didn't people we didn't have um
access to um that like you know mediums
that could proliferate information so
quickly and so efficiently but now i
think especially as societal attitudes
change too um especially in repeat
regards to what's acceptable and what's
not acceptable in term and um
so i think yeah and i think that no i
guess like yeah it's just it's hard to
being i would just say it's hard being a
celebrity these days because no matter
what you say so oh there's always going
to be someone who's like um i think who
will have something to say about it
whether it's a think piece or whether
it's like i don't know some random
youtube comment
yeah yeah there was even a
recent way of viewing things from a
multi-decade-long process which i
thought was interesting people that have
been around for uh almost like a half
century that they have said things that
back in the day it was completely
different trying to get press now you
can just make a twitter post and it's
called press exactly right so it's just
a democratization of the dissemination
of information but there's a lot more um
that that's doing
across the world um
okay so let's jump back to um the high
school days so so how did you end up
figuring out that you wanted uh uh to go
like ivy league style and what's that
like what's what's that whole process
like of who you were in high school no
so the thing like now that i think about
it in retrospect um i think the only
reason i strive for those schools is
because like oh it's always good to
strive for the best and i think but now
that i read now that i think more about
it i'm really really grateful for having
had the opportunity to attend those
institutions especially in terms i think
when especially when um bringing up to
return to the conversation about ses
like socioeconomic status there's some i
think when it comes i think education is
one of those things that um can really
catapult catapult people who are like
you know from a certain ses and to a
higher level ses within one generation
yeah that's a huge point it's almost as
though if you
work really hard for one generation you
can start surrounding yourself with a
couple of potentially income brackets
higher exactly your previous generation
and then build on that i mean but then
again it's like it's not not to say that
it's easy though or anything because
of course i mean i think so and not to
say that it's all only about sesc yeah
but it's not only about us i think yeah
there's so many factors that um go into
college admissions honestly i think i
feel lucky that like okay i um you know
i got in when i got in because i can
only to be honest i can only see it
getting more competitive unless there's
some great revolution then i think it's
only going to get more and more
cutthroat
it's already damn cutthroat because you
were like you were like a great amazing
gpa amazing test scores amazing
extracurriculars amazing essay writing
and you got into ivy leagues and then on
top of that then there's the
limitation in spots that's going on
there's people from around the world
that are applying not just
yeah and i think it's just crazy because
um it didn't occur to me until i
actually set foot on campus but they're
actually like just like it's crazy
because some people have been like
groomed there for their entire lives for
success where and then i think
especially when you go to like certain
private schools too the way that their
um curriculum and like um their
requirements are set up or is that that
it it actually it makes you be
successful in the college application
processes because you have to do ex
extracurricular you have to take certain
classes
um so it and it's and then of course
then it's like you're if you go to like
certain part in private school then like
your parents it's very likely that your
parents have likely have access to more
resources too
um
but yeah i think when i was in high
school to be honest i hadn't really
thought about it on all this college
stuff until like my sophomore junior
year so i think i also perhaps i got
like maybe perhaps i got lucky a little
too
it's so important to identify that we
get lucky
a lot of we see a lot of people run
around with a mentality of what i earned
everything was
but it's so important to say that we
stand on the shoulders of giants that
already made
ubiquity and food and electricity and
water and so many of the things that we
get to build on top of and even then we
got lucky a bunch in our lives you know
i did you did and so many people do and
so it's important to be humble about
about that
yeah okay so give us uh give us the now
so it ended up being harvard it ended up
being where you ended up going and that
was uh class of 2016. yep yeah so that
was from 2012 2016 harvard this is
actually an interesting point i
mentioned this to you um and i think
this is an interesting thing that people
keep talking about is that you you're
like you're such an exceptional figure
at your high school and then you go to
your ivy league college and then you're
surrounded by other exceptional figures
and then it's like whoa
because then you you're it's just a
total change in perspective i mean to be
honest i feel like every single person
at harvard experiences that to some
extent especially i think especially the
more unprepared you come too
like
at least for me when i was in high
school i could put the minimal amount of
effort into you know excite like
studying and still get like let's say
perfect scores on tests where but
whereas in college okay you're out in
the big open world for the first time
with no parental supervision
and then um not and not only that and in
most like public schools like you know
it's like your day is already laid out
for you you have to go to this class and
then you have to go to this class and
you have to go to this class where but
in college um your schedule is a lot
more flexible and also and it's not like
they're going and the professors don't
hold your hand in terms of the
curriculum you have to become prepared
to class in order to learn well and you
also have to be proactive in your
learning too so there's not so there's
already that like um you know factor but
then there's also it was also i feel
like there was also a culture shock for
me but because i think i guess like so i
came from a high school where um a
really big public high school where like
i mentioned before um it was really
diverse not only in terms of race and
ethnicity but also just like
socio-economic status and i feel like at
places at like harvard and other um
elite institute institutions
you don't necessarily have that
diversity what you could say that like i
mean that you don't um
you know you could say like you could
say that in terms of racial diversity in
terms of socioeconomic status but i
think there's one but one really
incredible thing about these
institutions though is that i feel like
you get um people like with some lots of
different life experiences and
viewpoints even
it's it's as though you take
the
the best of a bunch of different local
areas and across the world and you bring
them to one point and this is very
that's kind of exciting it reminds me a
little bit about kind of like what it's
like to be at like google campus oh yeah
totally yeah uh-huh yeah
and and and to be
there or to be at harvard right to be at
these sort of like epicenters of an of
an intellectual uh
group that is already worked quite hard
to achieve
something in their lives already that's
exciting and then trying to learn from a
bunch of the different ones about what
their world perspectives are what
they're doing you decide in on physics
which is exciting
so like what was that like to figure out
that it ended up being physics well i
guess like going into harvard i already
knew i wanted to study physics i think
probably because i had some good physics
teachers in high school
and also i think i just felt like okay
um it's it's fun it's interesting it's
also very um
it's also very good to be honest like
not going to lie it's also very um you
know it's like something that you can
put on your resume and then people and
then you and like it looks good on your
resume too
okay and then
now what is the like for you give us
kind of like a snapshot of what
some of like the most
profound takeaways were for you in that
four year period hmm
well
oh man i'm just i'm trying to like think
of all the academic material now and i'm
like
i'm like uh i haven't done physics in a
long time
oh man
and
just like off the top of my head though
i i guess like
in terms of like profound takeaways
i guess like one
i guess like well i guess like we all
for one thing i like take always take
always like look around you and take
advantage of all the opportunities that
are around you and so okay so and i
guess like to give a concrete example i
really i sort of regret how i didn't
take advantage of all the wonderful
opportunities at harvard so for like for
example um getting funding to do certain
things like um let's say funding for
study abroad programs going to places
that you would have like never dreamed
of or getting funding to do um certain
projects or to pursue like um certain
things i think like especially um one
like yeah i guess like one interesting
thing about harvard is that like oh when
you like when your club wants to invite
uh speaker to campus it just say just
say like oh we're from harvard and that
probably priced their attention
i like how you brought up you know carpe
diem you know seizing the day seizing
these opportunities that come
the doors that are presented to you
open walk through them go through those
exactly
and that's a way to maximize your
potential in the world
you end up figuring out that you could
have learned potentially so many so much
different information when you went and
maybe studied abroad or when you
actually reached out to those couple
speakers to have them mentor you to have
them speak at your organization or go
and take the risk of getting involved
with different projects um i'm glad you
brought that up
yeah i guess yeah exactly oh man i'm
just thinking about all the things i
could have done but i guess it's never
too late um even when you leave college
yeah i think yeah sorry okay the whitney
and all the other uh
concurrently running parallel universes
are exploring the things that you didn't
get a chance to do with this one
i don't know i hope um i hope um i hope
those whitneys converge into this
timeline soon they do they all yeah you
tap into all of them at the same time
yeah okay so
now okay so now 2016 comes around and
you're figuring out um this is actually
interesting because you ended up doing a
lot of work in data yep and i actually
thought this was really cool because
uh there seems to be a growing movement
for
outcome-oriented uh data in healthcare
exactly uh-huh tell teach us about this
sure well actually um i'm not too to be
honest i'm not too familiar with um
health care care like the nitty-gritty
of healthcare data science that sort of
stuff but um recently i worked for um
the accountable care organization um
like um part of the massachusetts
medicaid program
so mass health provides um you know like
um health like health insurance for like
let's say millions of members in
massachusetts state and i had the
opportunity to work within their payment
reform division um on this aco program
so i actually well i didn't work on the
policy or the operational side i worked
on data management it was a really
educational experience for me overall
yeah we're transitioning to outcomes on
the healthcare side of things
and that's so important to make sure
that people are actually healthy and
that when they come into our
institutions that they leave healthier
there's a lot of weird corruption that's
that's that's occurring that we need to
actually take a a a second third fourth
glance at and uh and solve
so okay so what has what's go what's
going on with okay we're like you know
we're like 25 26 and we're you know
mid-20s and there's so many people that
are graduating college that are like you
know they're
they're in many ways they're struggling
to find meaning in their lives
and
it's hard because we even go through
these ups and downs like one day you're
roaring with meetings and the next day
you're like
so meaningless what's going on so what
how does one find a sustained
sense of meaning well so for one thing i
am one of those 20-something year olds
and i'm also struggling to find meaning
in life my own life so perhaps this is
the blind leading the blind but um
i i think from what i figured out so far
though i think um
i would i guess i might like i first i
at first i think okay i started chasing
just hedonistic materialistic things but
and there's nothing wrong in chasing
those things too but more often than not
um chasing those things um i think they
only provide
ephemeral temporary relief
but i think
and i guess like what i guess like when
some the first thing that comes to mind
in terms of what gives me meaning to my
life is um having genuine valuable
connections with people and when i say
valuable i don't just mean that in a
materialistic or a transactional way um
i think like
one thing that you especially learn when
going to elite institutions like harvard
is that um
i think a lot of people there tend to
see relationships in the transactional
way like who can you refer me to who do
you know can you get me into this like
sorority or club can you like get me a
referral for this job and i don't blame
them because i think it's just it's just
a really cutthroat environment it really
fosters that attitude but it doesn't
necessarily have to be like that all the
time and
i guess having transactional
relationships itself isn't a bad thing
especially if like if they're mutually
beneficial then that's good but then i
don't think it's that bad to want to
have um genuine relationships either
with genuine human connection
whoa i like where you took us there okay
so there's this sort of
there's a spirit that one can move
themselves with through the world that
is a loving kind essence to everyone to
all humans yep period
and then further than that it's like
okay well what brings you meaning okay
well maybe it's for me it's building
this project and then of course i'm
going to look for people that i think
are interesting to sit down and talk to
and so then that's the idea of finding
like utility and i was i'm i'm i'm
really just i'm hesitant to even like
start just trying to intellectualize
what being transactional or
materialistic or right all these
different things are it's if you carry
yourself with that unconditional love
period it's almost as though things kind
of just come they come to you you give
you come and give things
arise and go yeah yeah that's that's a
really interesting point it's something
i've actually been thinking about
recently too i think a lot a lot of
things i think one thing that a lot of
people my age especially like when you
come look especially people who um who
have um who have let's say um i guess
like grew up with like asian immigrant
parents is that i think you know it's
like you struggle to think about oh what
value am i giving to people i think um a
lot one theme that i've noticed among
like um like like second generation
asian children like
those whose parents were immigrants it's
often it's that oh like no matter how
well you do it seems like it's never
enough you're always going to be
compared to like cousins so and
so-and-so who plays the piano or even if
like you could be a world-class like
violinist and you you have three ivy
league degrees and you're an astronaut
and a doctor and whatnot but then still
like oh why aren't you married yeah
where's my grandkids
damn that's
legitimately a parenting conversation
that occurs yeah oh yeah and it's not of
course it's not just something limited
to asian immigrant parents i feel like
it's something that like um that like
it's probably like um something that
like you know people a lot of people our
generation feel like the idea of um just
comparing your like just being compared
to other people and the idea that oh
it's like am i ever good enough
gosh that one sits oh
it's um
you know mr rogers did a really good job
at uh telling people that they are good
enough and that they are loved as they
are and that
there is a
it's such a
it's a soothing and calming feeling to
know that one is loved and that um that
one is love and that they do provide
that love to others
as well
yeah it's hard yeah it's like it's hard
to embrace that feeling because i just
think or at least like so to go back to
your point about like if you live your
life sincerely with loving kindness then
you don't have to be transactional then
things that loving kindness and like and
i guess like and the material ways in
which that manifests will come to you
naturally and organically it's something
that i think okay i should notice um on
a i should notice already i should live
my life that way but i guess if i feel
resistant to live it that way because
i'm afraid i'm afraid that like oh what
if like i like i live my life that way
but then i'm taking it taken advantage
of or like i'm left with nothing
there's a
feeling of slight vigilance with love
that it's because there will be
a
a slow fading of
of the
malevolent instances that you speak of
they'll fade away over time but to
remain a little bit vigilant as you go
is important so you carry the wake of
positivity and love and then
stay slightly vigilant as you go through
to make sure that you can continue
bringing forth yourself fully right like
so so setting healthy boundaries for
yourself
so that you um i guess like one way you
could put it is that um set healthy
boundaries for yourself and um you'll be
able to um love yourself as well and
that helps you um i guess like give to
other people
yeah if you take a
uh
a practice in
like future authoring goal setting
conscientiousness
just
see if maybe if i choose to pursue a
non-hedonistic thing for a week or a
month
that i take something off of the list
and i just add something else maybe
creative to the list something else that
could unlock a new way of thinking for
me
and i do that for a week or a month
what would happen and then you just do
you know self quantify itself you just
analyze yourself afterwards or how you
feel after that week or month
these are the sort of thing ways that
you can actually figure out who you are
better
yeah yeah i agree with that but i think
like
i couldn't help but think about an
earlier part of our conversation um
where we where i mentioned how um us
millennials were so burned out all the
time is because um
we feel like we have to optimize every
part of our life and then i guess
another
in and then as a as a result we were
expected to be productive all the time
so we feel bad if we're not being
productive and hence even mundane tasks
like i don't know filing your taxes or
take or like um you know sending a form
that are supposed to be um you know
they're supposed to technically they're
supposed to be easy well i guess filing
your taxes isn't a good example but yeah
sending like let's say sending a voter
registration form or um giving a call to
like your primary care provider or like
going to the pharmacy to pick up your
prescription those things are
technically mundane technically very
easy but you feel resistance to doing
those as well
that's such an interesting point because
that happens all the time with the
mundane sort of i have to go drop off a
physical
letter at the post office
and it's like
uh
uh what can i do with that half hour of
my life i could do something else um
there's so many
things like that that even
the optimization for food is just like
i'm gonna drink soylent instead of have
to go
and like what is food anymore
oh man
i i hope i don't want to be in a room
with people who've only eaten
i imagine that was adjusting to your
digestive system
very strange to test what it is like to
consume that for
years or so
um
this is this is a
important subject that we're talking
about i've there's there's um there's
such a rage for productivity and that is
all affecting mental health and
it's the
where's the meditative spirit
yeah i think i think especially of
course it sounds like it sounds like i'm
like raging in social media all the time
but i think i don't have anything
against social media i love it i scroll
like i scroll it i you know i scroll on
facebook all the time
but i think um and i think like in like
the idea that that we are supposed to be
productive all the time also ties into
the idea that um we have to project the
best image of ourselves all the time too
so when i say that we're supposed to
optimize even our leisure activities i
think that like
i i me i mean that by saying oh like we
have to project the best image of
ourselves on our social media we we have
to cultivate even like our leisure
activities to seem like we're doing the
best things all the time or at least
like show the best parts of ourselves
yeah ain't nobody taking a
an insta story on the way to the post
office i'm going to drop off a letter
right now exactly
it's always that this super profound
moment of my life that i'm capturing and
sharing with other people where i look
the best and
and
yeah one of my one of my friends
um shout out to casey and
also and my and myself occasionally
will purposely take
photos that are not the most uh good
looking
of ourselves and post those because
that it changes the culture and it's
those little things that if you if you
upload
the more potentially the more
mundane or not as
as pinnacle-appearing ones that that
could actually potentially let other
people be like yeah it's fine to not
wear makeup or it's fine to for me to to
do a little bit of like listen something
or whatever you know yeah i think i
really respect them or like i really
respect people who are able to post
about their vulnerable vulnerable
moments on facebook too like um i think
yeah that's something i really respect
well i don't know i don't think there's
any i don't think there's anything like
inherently bad and wanting to share like
those wonderful shining moments like oh
i just ate something really delicious or
oh here's like a thirst trap picture of
me um
but um i really do have um i think it's
like i yeah i really um i really value
people who are able to share like more
of um they're more in like how do i not
necessarily intimate but just more
meaningful or like not in like moments
on facebook where like okay it's like
okay like okay i admit i'm not feeling
the best right now or okay like
something's bad happened to me um so and
then i think like people who can ask
like for help too i think is also like
yeah i think that's like a very valuable
utility of these platforms that gets
underused
asking for help and sharing vulnerable
stories i totally agree that that's such
an under utilized part of being able to
talk to others on social platforms
okay i wanna do some uh power round
thoughts okay what do you think
is
sort of transcendent of the human
experience some people call it god or
all that is or whatever exists past the
three-dimensional reality you know what
do you think the simulation what do you
think about about that transcendent of
the human experience could you
collaborate on that a little more yeah
some people think that there's there's
some sort of a a an ethereal power
within the cosmos
you know or that there that it is a
simulator or that it isn't god or that
it is and you are a character and then
what do you think about things like that
well without um without getting into
metaphysical things or spiritual things
i guess like one thing that does
transcend the human experience is
narratives and stories and this and the
tropes that make up those stories um
it's something this is something i've
been thinking about for a while but i
think a lot i think or at least like i'm
the type of person who likes to daydream
a lot and come up with stories in my
head scenarios of people and especially
like oh sometimes like i think about oh
what if what would happen if like
something else happened or i'm
daydreaming about um oh what if like i
got into this like or what if this
scenario happened with like you know
with like with the people in my life as
the characters or like the npcs if this
was for a video game
um
i think that even if the tropes that
appear in stories may not always hold
true in real life i think there's
something that's very tell like powerful
about them that causes us to perpetuate
those tropes even if they don't always
um
fulfill reality
what about what do you think is the most
beautiful thing in the world oh that's
another really good question
hmm but i guess
and one i think i have a i have a couple
of things in mind do i have to say just
one or can i say
i guess i guess like for i guess like
hmm
i guess one thing is just
i guess like like especially i guess
like coming from the experience of
someone who studied physics just like
how certain um
laws of nature just seem to work out so
well
um i think that without going into too
much detail i just think that's
something that's like very beautiful and
profound
another thing is um
yes having genuine human connection and
just realizing that you're loved by so
many people i know that sounds like
really cheesy but i think especially
when you're like um in a very dark like
during very dark moments or when you're
feeling really low you really us to
underestimate the um
the impact and the effect that you have
on other people so well okay maybe two
you are just like one in seven billion
people in this world or you and you
might not be the most influential
um there are still people who care about
you and people who would um notice if
you stop existing
but then the question becomes how long
do they how long do they notice
that lived and died before us today how
many can you name
100 maybe i don't know a thousand if you
give me some time yeah
out of 100 billion there yeah but i
guess like i mean and i don't think in
my lifetime that i can achieve
immortality and i don't i wouldn't want
to be immortal either because i think i
would just get annoyed at this after a
certain point just like seeing the same
people i don't know or i guess not on if
everyone else achieves immortality too
then i just see the same people over and
over again and it might get annoying and
if other people don't achieve
immortality like in a tuck everlasting
like sort of scenario
um then that would actually be sad just
jump into different designed virtual
worlds and then you can go explore
whatever you want yeah
i mean i guess like after a couple
thousand years um i guess like don't you
get bored yeah i guess but that's
another question missouri and where was
i going in oh that's that's funny so
after several thousand years would you
end up getting bored of all of the
different things that you can actually
do yep
okay um when is there something else
that you think we should cover on the
way hmm
[Music]
well we had a really interesting
conversation about simulacra on our ride
here and if i guess like if there's one
takeaway that i want to give to this
audience um
tonight it's that
social media like social media and the
projections of ourselves that we um put
on social media has led us to um living
living and living out these simulacra of
um what we think that our lives should
be like as opposed to what our lives
actually like so that this is so this
can like this can be um described in
many ways so um you think that people
are living always living the best
versions of their lives for example this
like i don't know maybe drake you see a
couple on facebook or instagram and they
always look always so well put together
and that their relationship is so
harmonious when behind the scenes you
don't know about like um all their art
their arguments or maybe it's just like
you don't know that they took a a
hundred different pictures and they
chose the best one to put online um
especially like so this is something
that's especially true for um women i
think um
you don't like it's like you see like
all these perfectly curated pictures and
a lot of them are usually like oh you
don't know like okay maybe it's just
like good lighting and makeup and even
like digital retouching that's like
really i think yeah that's especially
like getting more and more common with
like snapchat filters i think and um
it's like i feel like it's also like
much more prevalent in the east than it
is in the west to
excuse me so um you feel like you're
obligated to look a certain way when in
real and you feel obligated that um you
should be living a certain life but like
this this is just a collective illusion
um it's not like it's not the reality
it's not the reality what's real is
actually just like these mundane boring
sometimes ugly parts of our lives
along with the good parts of their lives
and interestingly enough a simulacrum
could potentially be a
a
any sort of a representation of
you you could pick whatever but it's
that we pick the
one percent that is the absolute cream
of the crop exactly we could pick the
most
mundane we could pick the most
entertaining we could pick the most
humorous or most artistic we could pick
any of those or a combination of them
that's a good point yep i like that
takeaway
winnie this has been a pleasure yeah
thanks for inviting me thank you thank
you thanks so much for talking to us
it's been a pleasure um there's a lot to
to take away from what it's like to
actually go through the process of
of being someone like
you this is good to talk to you yeah um
i'm like really honored to appear on the
show
thanks everyone thanks whitney thanks
for tuning in we greatly appreciate it
we'd love to hear some of your thoughts
in the comments below let us know
also do
uh build go create manifest your destiny
into the world everyone much love thank
you for tuning in and we'll see you soon
and live sincerely bye everyone bye